good afternoon we start with breaking
news and the former conservative mp
imran ahmed khan has been jailed today
for 18 months for sexually assaulting a
15 year old boy back in 2008.
he was sentenced earlier this afternoon
at southwark crown court sky shiman
freeman powell is there
and give us more can give us more detail
shimon
yes that's right the mp in rankhan
already had his backs packed as he was
in court earlier today and as you say he
was sentenced to 18 months in prison he
will have to serve half of that sentence
and will spend the rest of that time on
license and it was a really long
sentencing actually it lasted well over
an hour and a half and during that
sentence and the judge said that he did
not accept that khan had any remorse for
his actions instead he said that he felt
the only regret that khan felt was for
himself he said having found himself in
a predicament
he now faces due to actions 14 years ago
and of course this trial all comes from
the actions of 2008 and the jury heard
during the course of this trial that
khan had forced the youngster to drink
gin and tonic and then pushed him onto a
bed where he then asked him to watch
pornography now the victim made a
statement today the victim is of course
anonymous he cannot be named due to
legal reasons but he said that he's
spent the the remainder of this time
still living with the trauma and the
shock of what happened to him he said
that he is still scared vulnerable numb
shocked and surprised after that
incident in 2008 he said that khan had
touched his feet and legs and had come
within within a year's breath of his
private parts as he went to sleep on the
top of his bunk bed he also said that he
felt guilty that now his family has had
to relive this awful moment all over
again and that he's also struggled with
suicidal thoughts as well having it
during the course of this trial so he um
he also the judge story also spoke about
the fact that a report was made in 2018
but the victim didn't want to make a
formal complaint however he did file an
official complaint after khan won the
wakefield seat in december 2019 in that
general election and that was mentioned
a lot because khan's defense was that
that time was the best time of his life
he was extremely proud and he'd
dedicated his life to service trying to
help people and since all of this has
happened he's now fallen from grace he
said that um he since this has all
happened he's been splat at in the
street he no longer attends social
events he's been kicked out of his faith
groups as well as the conservative party
however the judge was more concerned
about the impact that it had on the
victim he said that it still had a huge
impact on his life and as i say he
wasn't convinced that he was actually
remorseful so khan will now serve 18
months while he's been given an 18-month
sentence he will serve half of that time
in prison and the rest are licensed
jamal thank you